tomorrow the clark county school board
could reverse its decision to fire
superintendent jar that major change
comes after trustee irene sepeta who
originally voted to fire him requested a
re-vote now kate houston exclusively
spoke to the school board president to
preview tomorrow's meeting and some of
the controversial items being discussed
kate
yes well despite three of the biggest
agenda items being about dr jara
district council informed trustee
cavazos that he will not be there
cavazos tells me she's hopeful there
will be civil discussions that allow
them to forge a path forward for the
district it didn't happen overnight
there are a lot of moving factors
that
are bringing it bring us to this
particular place nearly three weeks
after dr jarrah was fired and many still
want clarity on why it happened trustee
linda cavazo says it's not about why but
how they got here this includes the
trustees this includes
what is happening in our schools right
now you know what is the environment
like what is the school climate what is
the culture like trustee irene cepeda is
at the center of this decision cavazo
says it could be helpful for sepeda to
publicly discuss her reasoning it could
be healing and also speaking to the
greater community i think that it would
be
very transparent one agenda item could
select an outside expert to investigate
allegations of a hostile work
environment cavazo says she's open to a
fact-finding process and interviews on
both sides it would go both ways and if
that's something that they wanted to do
i am certainly open
to a discussion on that and being able
to get a lot of things out into the open
in all a key question still remains
would dr jarrah still want the position
if the vote is reversed
i have no idea
what is going to happen
even if it went in his favor i do not
know
if he would accept it would he decline
it
well i have reached out to the school
district and dr jarrah's attorneys
multiple times over the past few weeks
for an interview or for comment i have
not yet heard back that school board
meeting will be held tomorrow at 5 p.m
and kate one of the agenda items is
essentially appointing an interim
superintendent so this is especially
important if jara does not keep his job
do they have anyone specific in mind
well trustee cavazo says that
a lot of names are being floated around
right now and some individuals and
supporters have actually reached out to
her directly and trustees have agreed
that an interim superintendent will not
be in that full position and it's really
not going to be a drawn out process but
as of right now dr jarrah will be in his
role as superintendent until december
1st